We know immigration is a hot topic in
the United States,
and of course it's a polarizing subject.
You might be in favor of it,
we might be against it,
but you're unlikely to be neutral.
You're probably also think that
immigration is either an opportunity or
it's a threat,
and Jane Migration Ending Chain
Migration and canceling the visa
lottery.
President trump has railed against the
immigration family reunification program
since 2016,
making it a centerpiece of his campaign
for president,
but now that the first lady's parents,
his in laws have used the program to
have to become US citizens.
Critics are the ones having the field
day.
Shane migration is one of the disasters.
Chain migration is a disaster.
Disaster.
A total disaster chain migration,
however,
was in the United States.
There's another kind of immigration that
isn't talked about very much,
but which involves a huge flow of people
moving from one territory to another.
Every single.
Yeah,
I'm talking about interstate
immigration,
the kind of immigration that happens
between the states that make up the
entire country.
This is something that creates winners
and losers.
Steak,
sweet have losers.
We have losers.
Also,
folks after Donald Trump and the
republican party's latest fiscal reform
and everything indicates that this type
of immigration is going to grow.
Obviously,
as you can imagine,
people tend to immigrate to the most
prosperous territories.
So here are a few questions that you
might now be asking yourselves.
What interstate immigration trends are
happening in the United States?
What does this type of integration
entail?
Which states are the winners and which
are the losers?
Why and well,
what can we expect in the future?
Well,
let someone look at all of that.
Shall We?
Winners and losers.
Yeah.
Millions of Americans pack up their bags
and move to another state.
Some states have positive immigration
balances every year.
That is to say year after year more
compatriots arrive,
then leave,
and also of course the opposite happens.
Some states see many residents move to
another state every year,
many more than the number who arrive.
This is because states compete with each
other.
Of course,
each state has its own characteristics.
It's own regulations,
its own taxes,
policies,
and logically.
This makes some states much more
prosperous than others.
Obviously people tend to move to more
prosperous places to states where
there's more work,
there's better living conditions and
where more companies are being
established.
Well according to data from the irs or
internal revenue service,
the federal government agency
responsible for collecting taxes between
the end of 2015 and the start of 2016 to
two point eight percent of taxpayers and
moved to another state.
According to this information now,
and I assure you that the irs has the
best data in the United States,
the migration rates,
the internal mobility in the United
States is very and I mean very high
compared to other developed countries.
Having said this,
do you want to know which states that
the greatest migration read deficit that
is the states with the greatest
difference between Americans leaving and
arriving pay?
Yeah.
Well,
check this out.
Yes.
As you can see,
New York is in the lead as the least
attractive state for Americans to stay
in in net terms only in 2016 and
discounting arrivals more than 150,000
Americans
left.
It's followed by other states such as
Illinois,
New Jersey,
and California,
and really could anyone imagine the
California,
the land of technology,
gorgeous beaches in good weather would
be on this list.
Well,
there it is.
And now the opposite question.
What are the states with the greatest
migratory surplus of Americans?
Well,
check this out.
Florida with a positive balance of about
200,000 Americans has become the big
winner.
Mind you,
this information is from 2016,
but if instead of taking the data from
the last available,
yeah,
we looked at a longer period of time.
For example,
since the beginning of the 19 nineties,
the result is practically the same.
New York,
California,
and Illinois last,
the most Americans while Florida,
Arizona,
and Texas one the most.
And hold on a second here because this
is really much more important than you
might be thinking during the video we
made recently about the hidden debts of
the different states in America.
Well folks,
every time estate loses Americans,
it loses a bit of wealth.
For example,
the almost 200,000 Americans,
he moved to Florida in net terms in 2016
as an income of more than
$17,000,000,000 a year.
This is an income that from now on will
be produced within Florida positive.
This will be saved in the state's
financial entities while another part
will be spent in its stores and
supermarkets,
cinemas,
restaurants and gas stations,
and another part that will be invested
in new businesses that will be mainly
located within Florida.
All of this means more wealth,
more work,
and what tax revenues for the state.
So at this point you might be beginning
to see why this is quite so important.
However,
having seen all this,
the question does remain well,
what variables?
They explained this movement of people.
Well listen up competition.
There are many reasons why people move
from one place to another.
This family work,
climate opportunities,
universities,
plenty of things.
However,
if we take all of the data into our
accounts,
there are a couple of factors that
really stand out.
One of them is taxes
in 2016,
almost 600,000 people moved from the 25
states with the highest access to the 25
states with the lowest taxes.
In fact,
the 25 states with the highest taxes,
no less than 24 has a net immigration.
That is they so more Americans leaving.
Then arriving,
displaying while sometimes said internal
migration isn't motivated by the weather
or things like that.
Well,
California does suffer from this deficit
to state like New Hampshire,
which is small,
cold,
mountainous,
and has a narrow coastline.
They've recorded a surplus since the
year 2000 and listen up because Rhode
Island for Mon said,
Massachusetts all have much higher taxes
and they lose Americans every year and
yes,
New Hampshire is the state.
We're the second lowest taxes in the
United States.
Coincidence,
oh no.
Runs in the Midwest.
While South Dakota generally registers a
surplus of immigrants from year to year.
It's neighboring states,
Nebraska,
Iowa,
and Minnesota,
which has higher taxes,
have had migration deficits for five
consecutive years,
and then this Kentucky versus Tennessee
or California versus Nevada,
Texas versus Washington states with
higher taxes lose and states with lower
taxes.
When
Morris study done by economists from the
Treasury Department estimated that when
New Jersey raised at state income tax in
2004 by almost two point five points,
it caused more than $80 million as to
change residences every year.
That might not seem like much,
but the truth is that residents with
higher rates,
they pay proportionately more taxes.
Now,
hold on a second because with taxes come
regulations for example,
and perhaps especially those that affect
housing,
see a combination of high property taxes
and several regulations and limitations
make living in one particular state,
much more expensive than living in
another.
This is what happens in California.
California is fed up with housing costs
and taxes are fleeing state in big
numbers.
Folks renting an apartment in Las Vegas
or phoenix costs on average,
less than half of the cost of an
apartment in Los Angeles or San
Francisco.
Not much housing and a lot of demand led
to incredibly high price and of course
this makes moving to another state worth
it for many people,
even if they learn less.
So this has been the case so far and we
can see that the effect that all of this
has is very important.
States with a migration,
sepsis,
this have also been able to grow more
public because they have more attractive
policies for companies,
entrepreneurs and we've also seen yes,
but from now on,
everything indicates that the effects
will be even greater.
This is all thanks to Donald Trump and
the republican party's tax reform.
Listen up
more competition.
This
may be one of the best things that
Donald trump has done,
the fiscal reform at the end of 2017.
Not only humans,
improving taxation for companies,
but also boosting competition among the
states.
Until now,
the federal government subsidized parts
of estates taxes.
This is because they weren't deductible,
but what you paid to the state was
deducted from the taxes that you have to
pay to the federal government.
This is something that worked as an
incentive for states to raise taxes.
Tax Reform has limited the situation so
that the number of households that can
deduct so local and state taxes has
dropped from 42 million homes in 2017 to
about $70,
million in 2018 all while having a
smaller deduction amounts.
This has been the equivalent of an
automatic tax increase in the states
with higher taxes because now that
taxpayers will have to pay the state tax
and practically the entire federal tax.
For example,
according to the calculations of the
Cato Foundation,
a tax plan from the state of New York in
2017 would have received a rate of 33
percent on federal income tax and
$30,000 on state and local taxes.
It could have decreased federal taxes
like $10,000.
That is thanks to his deduction at state
and local taxes would have cost $20,000.
However,
with the new tax reform though now I
have to pay $30,000 for state and local
taxes,
which is 33 percent more.
And people really feel that asking,
so now the differences between the
states with the highest taxes in the
states with the lowest taxes is going to
be much greater perhaps at the high tax
states,
didn't have this federal crutch to prop
up their big spending.
They might have to cut taxes to stay
competitive.
Ronald Reagan as the Wall Street Journal
recently published as a boom in Florida
for wealthy boss who wants to purchase
real estate and to establish their
residents there.
And you know why?
Well,
it probably has something to do with the
fact that Florida doesn't have a state
income tax and that it's property taxes
are also relatively low.
Anyway,
she knew what this all means.
Well,
it means no less than a new era of
competition between the states of the
USA has begun from now on.
State governments will feel a lot more
pressure to manage their budgets well.
The good news is that the evidence
points to this being good for everyone.
Basically,
a growing rivalry between states is
beginning to develop behind the scenes a
rivalry to be the most desirable and
affordable place for US citizens to
live.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos.
Also,
please do check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media podcast,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that weren't online.
Also,
this channel is possible because of
Patriot and our patrons on that
platform.
Please do consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage,
and as always,
I'll see you in the second.
Disasters chain migration migration.